It's been proven that
most users dislike
creating and remembering
passwords to interact
with your site or app.
Indeed, surveys have shown
that more than half of them
will walk away if you ask them
to do yet another sign up.
Well, why is this?
One reason might be that
the more times they give out
personal details, the greater
the risk of them being phished.
Now, the Canadian
government recently
released statistics
on phishing, showing
that 156 million phishing emails
are sent every single day.
And of those, 16 million will
get through spam filters.
Of those, 8 million are opened.
And believe it or
not, 800,000 of them
will have their links
actually clicked on.
And of those, 80,000
people will give up
personal information-- per day.
Now, all of this is
motivation for us
to provide you with the best
possible technology that
lets your users use
an existing account
to be able to sign
into your app,
and to make the API
as easy as possible.
I'm Laurence Moroney,
and I'm going
to show you how you can sign
in with Google to your Android
app.
If you're familiar with
Google Play services,
you'll know all about
the Google API clients.
And until Google
Play services 8.3,
signing in with Google meant
connecting to this client
and handling a
bunch of exceptions
for things such as account
pickers or app permissions.
Well, it's much easier now.
And with the addition of the new
Google Sign In Options object,
with this, you can specify the
scopes that you want to access.
And in a vast majority of cases,
it's just as simple as this--
requesting the email scope.
Once you have this
object, you then
pass it to the Google API
client in the addAPI call.
And then you create an
intent, using it like this.
And when it gets
a result, you just
simply start an activity for it.
This activity will get a Google
Sign In Result object back.
And from it, you can
extract user details,
such as their email
address or their Google ID.
When they run your
code, they'll see this.
When they sign in
with Google, they'll
be asked for the account
that they want to sign with,
and then they'll be
simply signed in.
It's frictionless.
It's easy.
It's secure.
Most of all, like I said, it's
really easy for you to build.
It's also extensible, and
you can use this technology
to validate your users
on your back end servers.
That'll be the subject
of my next video.
But until then, check out
the Google Developer site
for more details on
building applications
that sign in with Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]